un conseil de défense sanitaire est
prévue mercredi emmanuel macron doit
présider justement ce conseil sanitaires
il dit aujourd'hui en tout cas assumer
ses choix
à l'issue du conseil européen vendredi
dernier le président de la république a
défendu sa stratégie de ne par confiner
le pays en janvier dernier
c'est ce que réclament et les français
on en parlait avec alexis poulain ce
matin c'est l'édito politique de la
matinale alexis dit bonjour bonjour
heureux de vous retrouver dans la
matinale de rtl france alors emmanuel
macron on lisait un instant il assume
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
qu'est ce que cela signifie et bien qu
il a du mal à assumer ses erreurs il ne
regrette rien rien de rien emmanuel
macron ça fait effectivement un énorme
contraste avec angela merkel qui elle
s'excuse devant le peuple allemand
devant ce choix de vouloir annuler
paquin d'une certaine façon pourrait
amener le maquereau sa stratégie est la
bonne et il continue droit dans le mur
c'est comme ça qu'on reconnaît un
champion il fonce il appuie sur le
champignon même si tous les voyants sont
au rouge parce qu'il veut passer la
ligne d'arrivée le premier or la ligne
d'arrivée c'est les cent mille morts et
elles risquent d'arriver très rapidement
cette ligne des cent mille morts
monsieur cent mille morts ce sera sans
doute le surnom d' emmanuel macron ils
s'en fichent ils assument parce que
aucun mea culpa comme il l'a dit il
remet une couche d'ailleurs ce week end
avec une interview au journal du
dimanche expliquant que sa stratégie est
la bonne qu'il n'y avait pas à confiner
en février puisque il n'y avait pas de
piquant février alors que beaucoup de
scientifiques disaient que le pic
viendrait en mars et il se réfugie
derrière le fait que justement les
scientifiques ne sont pas d'accord
beaucoup de rapports sont
contradictoires il a raison notamment
sur le confinement sur les couvre-feux
beaucoup de rapports pense que ces
mesures sont inutiles alors pourquoi
utilise style encore le couvre-feu et
les confinements ça reste à voir
il faut il faut savoir que la gestion
sanitaire des mâles macron depuis le
début est une gestion autoritaire
sécuritaire 40000 pv ont été dressés ce
week end un gérald darmanin était très
content de m'être de davantage
d'effectifs de police pour [ __ ] des
prunes et dpd c'est pas comme ça qu'on
soigne malheureusement emmanuel macron
de vie continue pensant qu'il faut
laisser les écoles ouvertes continuer à
les voir et on aura la litanie
habituelle
semaine après chaque semaine c'est à
dire un conseil de défense mercredi
matin où il devra encore dire que c'est
une semaine décisive prendre des
décisions puisque les chiffres qu'on
risque d'être mauvais et puis on aura
une conférence de presse sans doute de
jean castex jeudi soir ça reste à voir
mais voilà à peu près comment va se
dérouler la semaine avec cette idée que
le chef de l'état a toujours raison
c'est la france c'est comme ça mais en
attendant c'est toujours pas ce qui va
se passer
confinement pas confinement un
confinement qui n'en est pas aujourd'hui
une stratégie de la gestion la pénurie
en tout cas attendre selon vous dans les
jours qui viennent on vient sans doute
continuer d'avoir ces départements sous
surveillance avec davantage de
départements et de régions qui vont
fermer qui vont durcir leurs mesures
alors durcir ça veut dire quoi bien
couvre feu
ce pseudo confinement davantage d'amande
le risque c'est que les soignants en ai
marre de ce petit jeu une tribune
d'ailleurs a été signé par un plus d'une
cinquantaine d'entre eux en disant
qu'ils en avaient marre d'être de faire
une médecine d'urgence mais de guerre
qu'il n'avait jamais vu ça depuis les
attentats et encore c'était moins pire
en 2015 la ils doivent faire des choix
au quotidien ils n'ont pas les moyens de
faire leur travail et la réponse de
l'exécutif est le mépris et l'intendance
suivra
or il n'en est rien les hôpitaux sont en
sous-effectifs la stratégie de
l'exécutif n'est pas d'ouvrir délire
malgré les annonces d'olivier ferrand en
août 2020 on n'est pas du tout à douze
mille lits de réanimation ouvert on est
toujours autour des 5000 et puis les
bassins de vie importants que sont les
grands centres si tu adores paris
marseille et autres n'ont pas vu non
plus
davantage de moyens donc la stratégie
c'est de faire des transports sanitaires
ils sont refusés cette fois-ci par les
familles qui préfèrent avoir leurs
parents proches d'eux plutôt que de les
emmener en train ou en avion très loin
pour être soigné ça ne fonctionne pas
emmanuel macron dira peut-être que ça ne
marche pas il se prend le mur du réel et
puis il ya cette stratégie vaccinale
aussi on attend à la production qui
devrait arriver sur le sol français les
commandes alors miracle on a trouvé un
trésor de doses de vaccins astrazeneca
en italie plusieurs millions de doses 2
millions qui reviendrait à la france et
des vaccinodromes géant ouvert qui sont
vides faute de doses et donc voilà ce
que assume aujourd'hui et le maquereau
c'est à dire une déroute en rase
campagne alors alexis des soignants déjà
mal en point est ce qu'ils vont accepter
de continuer d'être traité ainsi non je
pense passer cette tribune que je viens
d'évoquer d'ailleurs le montrent il y à
il ya un ras-le-bol et ça ne peut pas
fonctionner si si nous gérons de cette
crise sanitaire avec un bras de fer
entre d'un côté les pouvoirs politiques
et de l'autre les responsables de la
santé et les soignants ça ne peut pas
marcher on l'a vu d'ailleurs lors de
cette visite d'hôpital où le malaise
était palpable entre les soignants et
malades mâcon qui étaient là pour dire
tenez bon tenez bon sans apporter de
réponses sans apporter de moyens quand
vous allez dans les hôpitaux aujourd'hui
c'est le manque de moyens qui vous
sautent au visage les brancards le fait
qu'on ne peut pas recevoir aujourd'hui
l'annulation des opérations d'urgence
que se passera-t-il si jamais un
accident de grande ampleur avait lieu le
risque est présent et certains soignants
lisez bien s'il faut faire le choix
entre deux de blessés et de malades et
bien ce moment là on appellera
directement l'elysée et ce sera monsieur
mâcon qu'il choisira qui d'autre est
soignée en priorité merci beaucoup
alexis poulain l'édito de la matinale
politique c'est à retrouver tous les
lundis matin dans la matinale de rtl
france et sur les réseaux sociaux